[Music]  it's only right to perform your  billboard hot 100  number one hit at the billboard awards  [Music]  and that's exactly what bts did with  dynamite  [Music]  the group even took home the award for  top social artist  bts the boys used their acceptance  speeches to thank their beloved army  thank you army for giving us this over  four years in a row  earlier this year bts told et about the  significance of their first song sung  completely in english oh you know 2020  has  been truly a rough year for many  and there were many surprises changes we  felt like that's hooray to be honest  with you  um we needed we thought we needed to  break them from that so we focused on  what we can do the best and that was the  music  and the performance you know and we  tried to get energy  and we wanted to give the energy back to  the world so you know  things are simple the world needs the  positive explosion  and we came with dynamite and boom